if you can see this type in
hey arnold
hey
arnold
all right
thank you this question comes from
jackie maroon now if i mispronounce your
name please i apologize i'm probably
going to repeatedly do so
please tell us your
myers-briggs
okay
there's a website online which i'll
display right now which has me
pegged as
and
infj which is false and for whatever
reason this has five votes
this is incorrect i'm an
introverted
type of person who relies heavily on my
intuition and i'm fairly quick to draw
conclusions and i happen to like to
think or love to think i engage
repeatedly in imperishable
continual
mental activity so that makes me
an int j
that is intj
in fact my first company was named int j
the word on the street so that's the
next user who's asking this question do
you believe that a psychedelic drug can
cut off your brain's natural filter
and that it allows you to see beyond the
veil of our reality i've never taken a
psychedelic but heard people say that
while taking dmt as a group they were
seeing the same thing
that they had a group hallucination
okay so that's the question
i believe there's evidence that
both are the case
that
psychedelics removes what
sifts
sensorily
and that it modulates what is existing
like an instagram filter as well
as for people reporting the same
experience i hear this repeatedly
but i don't know of any studies that
have been done on this at least not in a
major journal and i don't know why not
given how apparently replicable this
result is and
it seems like something that's easily
falsified
as for the term group hallucination i'm
not a fan of the term
it's
an unreliable construct and i can talk
more about that
afterward
in other words there is no such thing as
a mass hallucination you hear people say
this
al johnson says kurt big fan
do you meditate so i've tried and i
continually try but i don't find that it
helps
so i've discontinued it
and i've recontinued it many times and i
i just find that it doesn't help me i've
tried it for years it's difficult
generally to stress me
i don't have many
negative thoughts barring recent events
mental events let's say which if you're
a
frequent surveyor of the tow channel you
should
likely or you would likely know about
this
you can find out more about from the
carl firsten episode and the
ah almas episode
i talk
a minor bit about it toward the end of
the diana fosulka video as well
so i don't find that meditation helps my
sleeping
nor does it help my imagination so my
creativity
some people say that
meditation can function as a method of
almost sleep so seinfeld said that
transcendental meditation recharges his
batteries
that is to say if you need to nap for an
hour what you can do is meditate for 15
minutes or so instead and you should
feel
just as refreshed if not more i don't
find that to be the case
for myself
godfrey oppa says what is your interest
in mathematics
it's fun for me it's fun
it's also the language that the universe
uses to
well use this physically
at least it appears to be the language
that the universe uses physically
i also find it extremely
difficult at times and i tend to like to
do what's
mentally or cognitively difficult simply
to prove it to myself because i'm much
like david goggins
though he's with physical work
he will push himself to the physical
limit i like to do that for myself
mentally i push myself in the mental
domain as much as i can
in high school and university whenever
there are multiple choices for a course
i would
just ask the question which one's harder
if there was two versions of a math
course which one's the more abstract one
which one's the more difficult one i
will take that one the more difficult
one simply to bolster my
self-pride gonzo asks hey kurt i want to
learn physics where do i begin and where
do i go
well
it depends on which part of physics if
it's the theoretical end of the
physics spectrum then i would say
you could watch the crash course on
physics there will be a thumbnail right
now about that which gives an overview
it also gives general learning tips for
math and physics if it's more of the
practical that you're looking for then
brilliant is a great
website to use
and
well websites akin to that and also the
next question so caroline cherry says
would taking a course in linear algebra
familiarize someone about quantum
mechanics more than any other math
i would say yes and i would say that my
advice would be to master it
inside and out and backward and you'll
be
unstoppable
another course that's not talked about
much
is representation theory or another
field of mathematics representation
theory so representation theory and
linear algebra
i would say pick some course some
textbook
some
powerpoint slide and understand
each equation every implication arrow
every equality sign
every
theorem assiduously
every definition every detail and you'll
be extremely
powerful you'll have an anchor to rest
any future knowledge that's mathematical
or physical and even some in the
emotional spiritual domain personally i
like to be
as detailed as i possibly can
though
i understand that sometimes and often is
the case while detail can be more
befuddling than it is illuminating
and that's one of the reasons that
people well that's one of the reasons
why people in the popular science
domain like
for example neil degrasse tyson and so
on i keep picking on him but i don't
mean to i apologize neil but people like
him have
just inundated you repeatedly with the
same wave particle duality and gravity
is like a fabric of space-time bending
and so on and it doesn't give you much
of much insight
and it's as if you're still at the
elementary school level
so
what toe is aiming to do is
to bridge the gap between
where the
popul where i feel the popular science
people have been stuck for the past 40
years
so that's here and then where the
universities are there's a large
unaddressed segment of highly highly
motivated and
extremely intelligent and curious people
and that's the toe audience though it's
nowhere near as
philanthropic as i'm making it seem i'm
an extremely
self-serving person so much of toe if
not all of those essentially to rectify
my own bewilderment constantly i see
what other people say
sorry i see
other people saying so-and-so is obvious
to me it's not obvious almost none of it
is i'm creating what i wish existed for
my former self while illuminating my
future self so my current self my future
self and in a sense it's like a bridge
from the
past to the future simultaneously it's
difficult to explain
the problem with simplified explanation
is that they may be correct but then
they disorient you
and you think that the world can't
operate in that manner so for example
richard borchards said that he can't
understand biology because when reading
the biology textbooks he realizes that a
cell can't function in the manner that
the textbooks suggest
so another one is the curvature of
space-time is like a balloon in the
middle of a bed and so on you get a
siphon it's like a black hole and it
just leaves much to be desired for me it
leaves more questions than
in answers that is to say that one can
make analogies with those analogies and
then they break down and it it tends to
be only after years and years of
studying
does
one realize that those reduced
explanations those simplified
low resolution explanations do indeed
accurately represent
what's trying to be explained however
you have to see it from different
vantage points
in order for you to see why squinting
with your eyes at this intricate object
produces that simplified image
explaining
some concept in a manner that a child
would understand sure a child would
think that they understand it but the
inquisitive child
would realize that well that can't be
how the world works and it's only after
one delves deeper into the
details or the particularities of a
given topic that
you come to realize that the boiled down
version is actually extremely lucid and
clever so caroline all of that is to say
understand pick some subject some
lecture some powerpoint slide if you
want to make it as
tiny as that
and understand it understand every
single equation every single equal sign
every single
implication arrow because broadly
speaking
understanding mathematics
or physics happens in three stages so
one is the
childlike simplified explanation that
we're all told and
we're all pretty much at that level
because
we've been told about string theory as
well you take an extended region of a
of an electron you make it into a loop
or you make it into an open string well
then you wonder well how does it operate
okay so you have some high level
understanding of it so that's stage one
then stage two is the rigorous
definition
then stage three is
the level of understanding where you
then see why this rigorous definition
makes sense with the initial one and
vice versa where it becomes intuitive
now the toe podcast you can think of it
as
coming to the understanding that the
majority of people are already at stage
one and they're being talked to
consistently like they're not at stage
one like they're at stage zero
and we need to progress to stage two and
then
hopefully stage three so the toe podcast
is about stage two the universities are
about stage three but that's extremely
difficult
victor yaki can you share with your
audience what you're reading
to prepare for specific upcoming videos
i think it would help a previously
unstudied but curious mind like my own
learn
even more
so let's say i have an interview coming
up i look up the person's corpus usually
it's a person rather than a
group of people and then i see what
interviews they've done what academic
articles they've published i may sort
that by most cited or most interesting
to myself
i make a note of any relevant other
infos like books they may have written
or articles written about them i try to
read
enough of
other people's commentary as well as
their own commentary on their work to
get an understanding of their point of
view i may do a
podcast on what it takes to prepare for
a tow podcast
i may do not a podcast maybe a video
let's say
and if people are interested let me know
step up startup enjoy your time away
what i find super fascinating about you
is your pause moments
in
pause moments
how in the heat of the conversation
you're able to do it and analyze and
come back with a very authentic point
instead of getting lost or taken away
you must be mentally drained afterward
because it takes plenty of energy on
that subject do you take any supplements
for focus or have a diet i know you
mentioned that you don't eat before your
conversations
so for supplements
for focus no
i've
tried virtually every nootropic that
exists and i don't find any of them
works for me except for caffeine and
venobut however
the latter i take perhaps maybe once
every two months or even less because i
am terribly
afraid of getting addicted to any of
these supplements or substances as for
fasting i almost never
eat prior to a podcast
for whatever reason i feel like it's
cheating
it's like me being
a serient in some manner
and so
i put it off until i have my reward so
it's almost like i feel like the same
feeling that i get if i was to eat my
dessert prior to the salad is the
feeling that i get
that same feeling of
of voraciousness indulging in my own
voraciousness
as
if i was to eat prior to a podcast to me
it's not
it's not decorous it's not correct it's
not right i need to do the podcast and
then reward myself with food and i love
i love food i i
surf it i gorge i gorge myself past the
point of over saturated
sorry past the point of over saturation
i love to eat this one of my i love to
eat with my wife
like i don't like to eat alone i love to
eat with my wife additionally when it
comes to the fasting i don't frequently
fast i intermittently fast virtually
every day but i don't fast for 48 hours
or 72 hours
except perhaps once a month or or once
every two weeks or so
and the reasons for fasting aren't to do
with cognition but instead simply timing
i don't have the time
to eat
i find that
i like to reward myself
by eating
afterwards so i eat just once a day or
twice a day and that's after i've done
the majority of my work if not all of my
work to sum up i'm a glutton
i
i
relish food
and
i treat it sacredly
fanny ram
how much do you usually prep for a talk
and how much of a free ride do you get
from your educational background
brackets undergrad
i
tend to have to relearn almost all of
what i've learned as an undergrad and i
realized that i had mislead it back then
if i've learned it at all
which is why in the crash course on
physics i go through details of how
how i think a particular physical
concept should be thought of or physics
should be taught or mathematics should
be taught and it's
to avoid this the confusion that i had
i was never the type to study in groups
nor ask the professor for help and that
has hindered me
greatly because much of how
people study is in groups if you go to a
university and you see a study group
almost all of their misapprehensions are
settled there whereas for me i don't
have that and i wasn't
i wasn't open enough to talk to other
people when i was in university and i
just feel like i have
virtually no one to talk to so almost
all of me trying to solve my own
non-comprehensions
happen solitarily
so for example one would be how does a
certain lead group sit inside another
league group i have to figure that out
on my own by reading and by watching
videos and
it's
extremely painful and protracted as for
how long does it usually take to prepare
i would say about a week
per interviewee so that's six
full days of
work
okay now fanny ram has
a second part to this if you are a
non-math major say engineering how long
would it take for you to get up to speed
with gauge theories
that depends heavily on who is teaching
it so if you're lucky enough to have a
great teacher then well it can be
extremely quickly the issue is that as
soon as you've
learned some subject it becomes
extremely
easy to underestimate how arduous it was
to learn that subject to begin with how
difficult the concept is and
one is trying to explain
to a student who has no clue what this
i'm trying to explain i'm trying to do
this vaguely and i i think it would be
better if i gave a concrete example but
hopefully you can understand what i'm
saying
when you finally understand something
you take for granted how difficult it is
to come to that understanding especially
after there's been some time from once
you finally understand it to when you're
teaching it so
many teachers
don't see where the confusions lie for
students because they've forgotten
what it's like to
not understand the concept the
people who are most skilled at
researching aren't necessarily the best
lecturers in fact at the university of
toronto they don't hire based on
lecturing abilities almost at all
they hire based on your ability to
conduct research and advance the field
and those
aren't the same so you can look up the
well you can look up a lecture on yang
mills theory by david gross i think it
was about the yang mills
millennium prize puzzle and you can see
how scattered it is you can also see how
he doesn't write
in any clear manner and that person
david gross is a nobel prize winning
physicist he's at the top of his domain
it's rare that you get individuals like
ed whitton and terry tao who are
masterful at teaching and they're at the
peak of their subject so
to answer the question if you're
studying by yourself then maybe it would
take one year if you're studying under
someone who knows
then maybe it would just take a month
stephen wolf from now this is a third
part to the same
user fanny ram stephen wolfram
speculates particles are tiny black
holes does pius's theory look consistent
with that i don't think so i need to
understand what wolfram means when he
says that particles are like tiny black
holes you'll hear from many places that
some object is related to some profound
one some benign some let's say some
mundane object is related to some
profound one and vice versa
in virtually every
toe that's advanced
especially the more imaginative ones
they tend to lack the rigor
though this isn't the case where wolfram
he's indeed rigorous as rigorous as
as anyone else
but i believe he's speculating using
analogies
and those and he's perhaps purposefully
being provocative perhaps not perhaps he
means those words in the way that
they're fairly literally interpreted
dark forest asks have you ever
considered writing a book and if so what
would be the subject matter i am writing
whether or not it's for publication or
my own edification that's to be
determined right now it's the latter
i see that people who have an extreme
amount of knowledge in a certain domain
tend to write a book about it but then
they get interviewed and then they get
criticized from people as being grifters
because they have something to promote
now
and it doesn't help
i don't think that's
i see people criticize many
i won't name names but
people criticize i think that's
something that needs to stop as soon as
there's a single
dollar motive then their entire emotive
is questioned and ideally you want
people to be doing what they like to do
or what they love to do for a living
ideally you would want
society constructed in such a manner
that people are doing what they love for
a living whether money is there or not
you ideally would like that it would be
great if everyone could
not have to do what they dislike and
contribute to society in themselves
when
people criticize
individuals for making money off of a
book or off of their knowledge well
often times they're
doing what they love to do and so by
criticizing and making money off of it
so by criticizing people for having a
financial motive it
gives the implication that
people shouldn't do what they love to do
and it gives that implication to others
but mainly to yourself it's one of those
phrases grifter and the word cult and
woo and there's certain phrases to me
that if one was to limit
or remove that from one's vocabulary you
would see how constructive and building
the world could be and yourself can be
those words are essentially
judgmental and dismissive
and
i i understand what it's like to be
judgmental and dismissive because that's
my nature i have that in spades i have
that to an abject degree i'm judgmental
and
disparaging
to others in my
internally
and i found that
the more i can disband just those words
the more that i
allow myself to put out an effort to
learn more about the subject from a
neutral to positive inquisitive stance a
loving stance if i'm at my best so those
words of that person's a grifter or that
person's a so-and-so i
i see this in myself as an indication
that i've
i have my own
internal
perimeters rather than it reflecting
something
of the objective world
and it's easy for myself and while it's
easy to delude oneself
into thinking that no this is just a
dispassionate assessment of
objective facts when it's actually a
justification for the limitation of
one's own knowledge or the
or a justification for not
trying to understand someone else's
point of view and steelman them
okay troy james monger says do you
intend to continue to
synthesize
a toe
into a grand unified toe documentary
you've gotten a lot of excellent
material would you consider a book or
something that recaps the beautiful
minds that you've surveyed
and that abstracted experience of
cataloging and foiling
as for a grand unified toe that's an
interesting way of
putting a troy
i have inklings here and there
at some point in a few years i'll have
something meaningful to say on the
matter
david shui or choi says
how would you solve the hard problem of
consciousness there's nothing about
physical parameters in terms of which we
can deduce what it feels like you can't
go from pure quantities to qualities
well i would say that i'm not trying to
solve the hard
problem i'm trying to understand the
hard problem and other problems
i think in about three years or so i may
have some
i may have a or multiple proposals for a
solution just judging by my own
intuitions
currently and the ideas that i
incessantly have
so perhaps in six to seven years i may
have
a verbally coherent formulated
idea or two or three as for the second
claim that there's nothing about
physical parameters and so on i don't
know
that's it's great that you have such
certainty i wish i shared that brian
redman says would what would be the holy
grail interview in your opinion
douglas hofstetter for me
daniel dennett
the dalai lama
and dan ariely so those are the four d's
let's say
and what's cropped up recently someone
that i would love to speak to would be
camille vasquez there's also the two
miyazaki's so that is the filmmaker and
the video game designer sahitaki
miyazaki and i've forgotten the first
name of the filmmaker i would love to
speak to either one of them and hideo
kojima who's a video game creator
i also would like to talk to todd howard
however i'm a sony fanboy and i'll be
boycotting starfield mike says
since you've begun this journey and have
been flooded with such deep intellectual
insight how has it affected you
personally what do you believe have you
noticed a change in yourself
is this
knowledge making a difference in your
life
and how you perceive or experience
reality does all of this intellectual
information increase a sense of knowing
or is it just the opposite
well i would say it's not pleasant in
many ways
in many many many many ways and it's
superlative in others
i wouldn't say that it's all
intellectual
theory
i say that because this medium even this
right now it's a video but it's also
propositional primarily propositional
but on the day to day it's experiential
and that's not something that people see
because they can't see it unless they're
around me
i've noticed changes in myself
and many others have noticed
changes as well in myself my wife has
the comments section is filled with
people who
claim to see that i've changed
in some manner i'm more grounded that's
certainly true
and
i'm generally embarrassed by how i
conduct
myself
three months prior to any given
time so i look back at an interview that
i've done two or three months ago and i
just cringe i can't watch it that to me
indicates some level of change
implicitly when gina says you mentioned
in toe with lou and sean that you have
an idea about the purpose of all of this
quote unquote
similar to christian love line enemy
union shadow integration
buddhist
loss of ego so i was wondering if you
could talk a little bit about how you
arrived at that idea
and do you have a formalized practice
practice for achieving this the state of
being
it's okay if it's too personal to share
she says
i
i wouldn't say that it's too personal to
share
i would say that it's just not
formulated
at a verbal level enough for me to share
in a manner that doesn't misguide rather
than guide or rather than
actually state what i
intend
the
inarticulacy
breeds the fear that
what's shared will be
misinterpreted
stu n says what is time is it a human
construct from long ago
that has just become more developed
without evolution from the scratches on
a cave to a nuclear clock or is it a
fundamental force of the universe i
don't know when it comes to time i
discussed that
a bit with
gen zed so i'll leave the link to that
podcast in the description
i will be exploring time
more on the podcast later this year i
know it's a controversial subject at
least it's a controversial subject to
not treat it as
obvious
however we all have allodoxa phobia
i just have to push through mine into
this
paradoxical and unsettled zone
nevermind says how happy are you from a
scale of 1 to 100 with how things are
going with the toe evolution can you
share one thing you're not satisfied
with and one thing you're extra proud of
so i would say i'm at 80 out of 100
and i'm just a covetous selfish
rivalrous person and the parts that i'm
not terribly happy with tend to be parts
where i feel like i'm underperforming
relative to
others or where i think i should be
but they generally are in comparison to
others there's this saying that you
shouldn't compare yourself to others and
you should compare yourself to yourself
but you have almost no idea of a
conception of self without a conception
of others so i think that's a flawed
statement
though there's obviously merit to it so
for example i'm upset with myself
for having a psychological issue or some
i don't want to call it a
i won't tiptoe around it but regardless
whatever has cropped up a few months ago
four months ago or so and that to me i
feel like has taken seven months i
imagine that it'll take me three more
months to get back to normalcy it's
taken seven months of
of my life in a sense from me i'm upset
with myself that i felt what i felt i'm
upset that i allowed myself to get in
the
condition where i could feel such dismay
and horror
and that because of it for the past
five months now or four and a half
months now
i've been functioning at a about thirty
percent my regular capacity
there's this there's many studies done
on sleeping and they suggest that if you
get less than seven hours of sleep
for two nights in a row it's like you're
missing
sleep
for an entire 24 hours
well i haven't had a night's rest that's
been more than six hours consistently
for weeks and weeks and weeks so i
imagine that's having an extreme
detrimental effect on my brain
and certainly my cognition i can feel it
and certainly my stamina i can feel that
so the parts that i'm thrilled thrilled
thrilled thrilled about is the effects
that toe has had on people
it's toe is essentially everything that
i would ideally like to do
outside of video editing
and and
luckily the patrons
helped me hire
a freelancer and the parts that i
that i'm extremely i can barely
i can't believe that i'm able to do this
and
well the parts that i love are the
researching of physics and toes in
general theories of everything in
general that i can try to understand the
universe and whatever that means and try
to understand consciousness quote
unquote whatever that means in free will
and speak to the brightest
minds of our time be able to do so at
home which fits my
umbratic nature and be able to work on
my own schedule as well
it's
as much a personal quest
like a transformational personal quest
quest as it is about explicating to
others and this is all being done
supported by people on patreon so i'm
supported by people who
like the
mission and want to see
for example i i've been taking some time
to study without placing out content for
about a month i'm able to do so because
of patreon
it's growing extremely quickly i'm
i'm thrilled about that especially for a
podcast as
as
specific as this one is it's fairly
technical it generally requires that
that you've watched many hours of this
person on someone else's channel to get
an introduction because i tend to not
make it introductory like other
larger podcasts the content is narrow
it's narrowly focused about
understanding reality rather than just
interviewing people who are popular for
the sake of interviewing people
so i'm i'm
i i'm extremely thrilled i can't believe
that i
i wake up
excited about work
almost every single day for the past two
years
i i'm
i'm thrilled with the majority of the
aspects of it video editing i don't like
to do luckily the patrons help with
a freelancer who is
graciously even editing this right now
so i get to focus on
on what i like to do what i love to do
mike duffy says what mic do you use
thanks so here's the mic i'll show a
video of that right now
and the reason why it's not great is
because every time i shake my leg
it stutters it and that's why often
you'll hear if you're listening
carefully you'll hear my audio shut off
automatically until i come back on and
speak and that's because
it's rumbling this mic and every time i
have the urge to urinate my leg shakes
dramatically and every time i'm nervous
i shake my leg as well so it's either
nervousness or a urination urge
dustin gibson says what tool are you
using to record your writing
so what he's referring to is the crash
course on physics again that'll be
listed somewhere along here
it's an ipad
i'm not a fan of apple products i don't
i don't use apple in any other
for any other reason it's just that they
have an unparalleled note-taking app and
the screen refresh rate is
120 hertz though i unwittingly bought
the model that was 60 hertz
i didn't realize that the more expensive
one was the one that was 120 i thought
they all had 120 so i would much prefer
if there was some android tablet or a
windows one that had 120 hertz and a
great note-taking app but
i'm using apple
in the interim
torico says kurt i wanted to ask you say
that you've gotten quicker at processing
and categorizing people's toes because
of how many times that you've done it
yes that's generally true tori and tori
says i would assume that you have
plenty of
once firm but now violently shaken
beliefs violently shaken is a great word
yes yes yes throughout your life and
experience of life as an aside
an academic article or
thesis of high caliber is akin to ikea
furniture the assembling of ikea
furniture
where one constructs the manual
so that's the thesis statement the
overview and then one places the screws
in various slots and the products on the
ground and
again gaining an overview of
more delineated objects specifically and
that's like the
mison plus if you were a
chef
or the statement of the paragraphs in a
academic thesis
and then toward the end it's all brought
together where you arrange it cohesively
and you present the final product now
the toe podcast or the toe channel
however one wants to conceptualize it is
much like that except without a manual
without knowing
how many pieces there are
if what you have is even complete
and you don't know what it's going to
look like finally you're guided by some
intuitions you see bits and detritus and
wreckage and you try to assemble it and
then you think you have a handle on it
but some new piece of information comes
in and you realize that what you thought
was a
shelf is a book case and then you
realize you're missing some large blocks
or this one doesn't fit and you realize
oh it's a refrigerator so in a sense you
have some model and you see that if this
was to look like what i think it is
i would need a screw here and a screw
here and a block here and so on and that
in this this analogy
for a
physics toe that would be like the
prediction of new particles and high
energy physics where you see that
there's some pattern except there are a
few missing
or it's like a missing cognitive piece
for a veltan xiaomi but you
search and search and you don't find it
so you have to recast what you think it
is from scratch
multiple times over tory cole says so in
the midst of there being no firm grant
ground to stand on that's true
to the extent of
to the extent of which you're familiar
enough to label and categorize
these shaken beliefs what belief do you
have that's not shaken enough to
continue to pursue toe and to even wake
up every morning
that there's a good worth striving for
and
that
i love my wife and she's worth almost
everything
and that my
darkest
thoughts about
doubting the good
and
it's difficult to talk about without
sounding
well
right right and then my let's say my
darkest thoughts
that are debilitating that
come from a doubtful nature can be
themselves doubted
and that it's arrogance for me to feel
so much suffering because i'm assuming
with my body
that
whatever model or conceptualization i
have
is
is
is true
and
the darkness was gotten to by doubting
benevolence or certain aspects of
reality so why not doubt the doubts
apply them to themselves and that gives
me some comfort
along with praying
which is strange to say
as an agnostic
because it's not like i have an
object to direct my prayers like an
entity
but i
i pray for faith
frequently
i i pray
for
for gratitude i express gratitude
i'm not grateful to anywhere near the
degree i i should be or i could be
and
the simple act of praying helps a great
great great great deal
mike duffy
says
for an ama can you do a quick overview
of your podcast setup and what equipment
you use if you want what i can do mike
is
and if anyone else is interested i can
do a
like i mentioned i i'm i can do a
separate video
of simply what it takes to prepare for a
tow podcast and go over my setup there
fanny ram says how many hours a day does
curt get to study how many hours for a
workout so i used to work about 12 hours
a day or so now i can do it for about
four or five hours though yesterday i i
did maybe 14 or 15 hours so it varies
but on average it's about four or five
now
given recent events
and working out is about 20 minutes to
30 minutes a day on average
fanny also asks kurt seems so well
studied thank you before an interview
sometimes without sleep that's true
how come he doesn't get divorced
so it's because i prioritize time with
my wife fanny it's what keeps me sane
it's also what makes life worth it for
myself i used to think that all that
matters is work
and i remember planning out a route to
be a billionaire
now
i don't even care about being a
millionaire
outside of the financial security that
owning a million or two provides clearly
such as being able to afford a home here
in toronto right now i'm a rent i'm
renting and pay for whatever my family
needs such as an emergency or to send my
parents on vacation
or buys
my in-laws a car
in terms of bills and so on
almost all i care about now is being a
good husband
and
that's that's been something that i've
come to the conclusion of over the past
couple months
it's
the
feeling that
all will fade in some manner
and that whatever prideful importance i
think i have firstly is
it's far less than i imagine and
secondly it's
even if it's the same as my inflated ego
wants to believe then this is only a
fleeting moment
if anything is worth
anything it has to stand the test of
something akin to time i don't say time
because i don't believe that
looking at some temporal duration is
what matters
but
it's something akin to time
and that there's an integral
connection between doing what's
temporary and what's sinful i'm using
plenty of
religious language i
i understand i i see and
if you like you can
convert it to whatever secular
version
or synonym you would like to if
you find that you're unable to conceive
of yourself as anything other than a
rational being
so then
if
whatever this is is only a moment
relatively speaking then it would be
worth every
little bit if it's with my wife
and if she feels adored and if i feel
the same and that's priceless there's
there's an infinite quality to that an
infinite quality to that
whatever else i
i do may be misrepresented and taken
from me diana posoka and i discussed
this that
people take the nirvana logo kids do and
they have no idea what nirvana music
sounds like or
the good fortune in san cri sanskrit
becomes the nazi symbol so it's it's as
if what you do escapes you after you've
done it additionally
whatever one does
will get
critiqued by those who are seeking
status
i know i do this frequently i'm
extremely jealous
and
we all are
i see it in myself thirdly it will be
forgotten in
decades or centuries
it's rare that it would last longer than
that so what will be worth it in the end
now in the end again i'm using time
there and i don't mean to it's just i
don't know if we have the
the language i think that it's all worth
it
in the end
if it's about harmony and forgiveness
and
and mercy and love and generosity
and i can feel that most with my wife
i feel it and i practice it and the more
that i'm able to do it with
with her the more i'm able to do that
broadly with others and feel it from
others
and even extend that to
say homeless people on the streets who i
never used to donate to
but now i have this
intimation that the quality of a society
is how we treat
the homeless people
in our society and i mean that at a
personal level not a governmental level
because as soon as you say well the
government should take care of it i
think they should
but that doesn't mean that you don't or
i don't have more way way more than
enough
to donate and help them
and speak to them like they're
they're people that aren't just the
receivers of
your
alimony nature so that you can feel
like you're doing something good when
it's
it's to
scratch that charitable urge
and it's
it's not coming from the right place and
you speak or at least i
would have
if i'm donating i would stand and give
them the money i think it's better to to
sit at their level their level even that
has a patronizing bend to it
but regardless to feel that
kindness
with my wife from my wife to my wife
it also helps me
retroactively change
the past and that's extremely
interesting because we talked about time
so how does that work i think about the
times that i've been hurt and there are
plenty of times and i
mainly think about the times that i've
been hurt
in relationships and so on and i'm able
to recontextualize them as positive
experiences now carl pilkington once
said that you don't know if you enjoyed
a vacation until years later because you
look back and you say well when i was
swinging on that swing set it started to
rain and i had to duck for cover and i
hated it at the time but i look back on
it fondly and i realized quote unquote
that i indeed enjoyed it it was fun
ricky gervais then interrupted and said
no no you didn't have fun
you look back and think it's fun but
that's not the same thing
and i remember agreeing with ricky i no
longer
i i don't know if i do any
anymore i don't know if it's the case
that however you felt in the past is
stamped down
and it's fixed i think that there's
something about recontextualizing
one's emotions about an event that
somehow actually changed the event
and well it's it's strange to think like
that because then you have to have as a
different basis something different than
materialism or physicalism
you have to somehow take the emotions as
primary and there are philosophical
strains that do so for example
phenomenology i don't know if if the
experience of the initial emotion has
some
canonical status over one's experience
now projecting onto the past it's not
clear to me at all it's intuitively not
clear and i think we all feel this
because we've had moments like this but
just because we feel it doesn't mean
it's true but doesn't mean it's not true
i'm still thinking about it so this
means that going back to the original
statement of me finding primary being a
good
husband
or a good son or good son of the good or
a good son of the universe or what
whatever this means
that somehow this has to do with being
kind
and
merciful
and
munificent
and
concerned and warm-hearted
it makes it not only worth it in the end
but it makes it worth it certainly in
the present but perhaps even in the past
which means it makes it eternally worth
it wittgenstein had a quote about this
by the way he said that if
if we were to take eternity not to mean
infinite temporal duration but
timelessness then an eternal life
belongs
or belong to those who live in the
present
i think he may be correct
though it takes an extreme amount of
courage to live in the present at least
for myself it's not it's it's no
trivially just no trifling trivial
matter
it's
extremely formidable
i think he's correct though i don't i
think that the mechanism may apply to
the future into the past as well
okay joseph pts wants to know would you
consider having eric back on to
specifically discuss the physics of
geometric unity
yes when i have the time to make a video
about how to go through a physics paper
that one currently doesn't understand so
i referenced that in the crash course on
physics and
i would like to tell you all about the
schedule but
i i don't have much
time left here this has already taken so
much more than i thought i am only about
a quarter of the way done i thought it'd
be half done or more the point of the
toe podcast is for it to lead somewhere
it's not simply interviewing people for
the sake of speaking to people that i'm
interested in
like rogan or lex or a russell brand
though they're great great great
podcasts
and
i'm i'm not diminishing them in the
least that's just not what toe is toe is
toe has a goal there's a trajectory
that's trying to be hit with virtually
every episode it's about explicating
toes and learning them deeply
agent nan says
theories like math and physics like
symmetry but the universe seems to be
asymmetric handedness chirality time
entropy matter
anti-dark why though are there any
insights from theory or experiment can
there be
there are there are elementary results
in mathematics that imply that at least
to myself that certain physics problems
aren't problems so for example the
hierarchy problem i don't see it as
being an issue the fact that gravity is
quote-unquote more weak than and
drastically more so than the
the strong force the weak force and so
on
because you can have symmetry in a
certain respect and then break it with
another there's a frobenius theorem
about that i can go into that in another
in another podcast if someone's
interested and then they're
also there are also problems where you
have a symmetry in the initial
conditions and even as a seeming
symmetry in the
problem that can lead to an asymmetric
solution so for example let's say you
have an equilateral triangle so you
think well what's more symmetric than an
equilateral triangle and then i say well
how do you populate that with three
spheres
such that you maximize the total area of
those spheres
so that what sorry spheres is in circles
i mean so you place a circle into an
equilateral triangle and you can make it
larger and then you place another one
but you're not allowed to overlap and
then you think well the solution should
look symmetric because the initial
conditions are symmetric a circle is
certainly symmetric the way that the
problem is stated doesn't seem to have
any asymmetry involved however the
solution looks like an equilateral
triangle with the circle
toward the top i'll see if i can
put an image and then two circles at the
bottom it's an asymmetric solution
so it's not clear to me that
what's required is always symmetry
breaking it could just be that a
symmetrically posed problem can have an
asymmetric solution
ghost i love your podcast but you don't
ever seem to believe if you had the
opportunity to see something paranormal
would you take it
i would say that i'm undecided right now
but i'm curious and i wouldn't say that
that's
that i disbelieve
i don't think that's the same as being
in a state of disbelief or disbelieving
and the answer just is no not right now
pancaj
tennija says has anyone studied the
properties of matter motion by imagining
all moments of the past in the present
concurrently extra dimensional view
question mark where it appears as a wave
of solid colors in a time-lapse image
seems like
it would have a wave property well okay
i'm i'm unclear as to
i'm sorry
pancash i'm unclear as to what the
question is
is stating though if what you
want is the past and the presence and so
on and so on concurrently the block
universe is something you can look up
will the electron
electrician says
now that you've talking with pius
salvador pius i'll leave a thumbnail
here if you're interested
and he said that
essentially next level physics is only
possible with plasma would you be
willing to do a deep dive on plasma
in particular with an interview with
montgomery childs of the sapphire
project
i will be talking to someone from the
sapphire project at some point i
contacted them and
that was around the time when i spoke to
ross coldheart and whenever they're
ready
for
the announcement of something new
they'll come onto the toe podcast that's
what they said
olivier
gothels says dear curt i love
your honest intent and the expressed
content of your channel my bold question
are you able and willing to invite
jordan peterson and bernardo castro for
a series of talks on your channel
i will say
olivier
perhaps in
24.
there are plenty of
plans for the tow channel in the latter
half of 2022 and
and certainly in 2023
plenty that's exciting
ho cha says any chance with jordan
peterson on your podcast and so on well
he interest he interviewed me
interestingly enough i didn't interview
him but i'll leave a link to that again
somewhere here and in the description
alvaro says
will christopher coke be on the show
someday yes
abnormal archive says when is nima
arkani hamad coming on i'm working on it
rakutamela says kurt i was thinking that
you could try to get in touch with lee
smolin and carlo rovelli for your next
interviews is this feasible carlo's done
already lee is someone i would like to
do but his health isn't the best
currently
skim sen says would you consider
facilitating a debate between stephen
pinker and bernardo castro
regarding rationality and intuition so
i'm working on that i there's plenty to
announce
ron devis says kurt have you ever
experienced personally ce5
no i
i don't
i haven't and i i would not like to at
least not right now john doe says
have you asked
well john doe says have you asked paul
stamets
to join you on a show he's one of my
favorite people along with shogin
alexander shulgin we'll see paul i mean
sorry we'll see john
michael manley says kurt are you
familiar with the work of david bentley
heart particularly his works on the
experience of god being consciousness
and bliss
i emailed
david a few years ago and he said yes he
would like to come on the podcast i
don't think it was named toe back then
that's how long ago it was i emailed
david
when the podcast was in its infancy and
he responded positively
i haven't had the opportunity to peruse
is
ubra let's say yet
though i would like to when i emailed
him i don't even think the podcast was
called toe that's so that's how long ago
it was
t soul x says
kurt what are your thoughts on nasim
hara means
theory from the resonance foundation any
chance he would be a guest so i have
heard of him many times i need to look
into his work it will take me many
months and likely by the end of the year
i'll be able to bundle him with several
other guests like clee irwin i'll see if
i can get to the schedule for the tow
podcast later in this ama by the way i
i released the schedule on the
on the patreon if you're interested
electric wheel says can you get bob
lazar on the podcast we will see
electric wheels by the way notice that
this is an entirely eclectic mix the
people that were mentioned previously in
the let's say the past three minutes or
four minutes
some people think it's strange to have
chomsky on the same channel as x or or
leo gura with
stewart hammer off or aliens mixing with
the fields medalists like richard
borchard's
i
it may seem strange but there
may be a convergence
and i don't know how to find such a
convergence unless i'm guided by my
supra consciousness so i wouldn't even
say subconsciousness it's something like
my intuition
and it seems strange when jung was
studying god and consciousness and
psychology those don't belong together
when leonardo da vinci was
combining and studying anatomy with
engineering with art
and newton by
studying alchemy and the bible and
physics
yet
newton's views on there being universal
laws were precipitated directly
by the
by his understanding of the omnipotence
and the omniscience
of god
so
it may seem bizarre that there's
such a
avant-garde mix but there's a possible
point of novel and
practical
confluence that i'm uncertain of how to
get to unless i am able to
unearth and explore extensively and
investigate with the
instincts that i have so the toll
podcast is it's strange it's not a
podcast i mean
it's it seems like a podcast but i just
don't know what else to call it it's as
if the way that i feel it's as if it's
in the 1900s and one was doing just film
in the midst of people doing 60 minute
long and 90 minute long films someone
started putting out 30 minute long films
and they had story lines that connected
when usually films are singular and
self-contained and then you would think
well that's not how film is done what
the heck is going on with this
and then it gets critiqued and evaluated
as film but you realize only decades and
decades later what the person was trying
to do was develop television in the
early days of film
but they didn't have the vocabulary to
call it television they didn't know what
they were doing they were guided by
something and
they
they were in a society with the
prevalence of film and because of its
resemblance to film it gets
collocated with film and evaluated with
the same rubric as film when
when the
rubric by which it should be evaluated
hasn't been invented and the filmmaker
themselves didn't know what they were
doing so that's what i imagine toe is
like i keep reiterating that toe is not
a podcast in so much as it's a project
the toe project is what i say frequently
and that's just because that's the best
word that i have for it the podcast is
the closest
form but i'm unsure if that's
if that's what toe is toe is you can
think of it as groping in the dark and
trying to understand some object before
light shines on it by the way there's
maybe some meaningful relationship
between the physical act of looking and
existence in and of itself that sounds
strange because we
have a society that is based in
materialism but the first step at least
for the intuitive types like myself is
to flounder
around in the stygian gloom
and then hope that something
positive occurs or that some light is
illuminated and something is felt and
some model is made
there's the mars rovers by the way which
i love the names of because i feel like
that's
what the
the toe channel or the toe project is
trying to do is follow them it's to
follow quote-unquote my curiosity
hopefully guided by my spirit
and to see what opportunities are
afforded to me at the time
u n
h
r e m n a asks
what is a theo locution
okay so
let's see i wrote this down
you can
think of a theolocution as an
advancement of knowledge rather than a
destruction which is generally the style
of debates
and that a theolocution is couched in
tenderness and respect so socrates used
questions and answers to generate new
knowledge that's called the socratic
method though he did so privately and if
it was in public the point of it wasn't
to do it publicly and he also did it
sardonically now contrasting this the
way that i like to think about the
what a theo locution is is the socratic
method plus
an audience plus fondness so that equals
a theolocution if you want to think of
it as a equation
so your ancestors danny says are from
india
indeed i am from toronto i was born in
trinidad my parents are from trinidad my
ancestors say the great great
great grandparents are from the west
indies ryan says ah shucks miss the ama
how can we know how to enter an ama and
when they come up whether this is my ama
or an ama with let's say pius salvator
pius and so on so i announce all of what
i plan on doing generally
far in advance on patreon and i give an
indication as to the direction for the
next few months regularly this is in
contrast to a call for questions which
are all which are generally done openly
on the youtube page
so if you want you can
sign up for the patreon
just so you know the patreon is the
virtually the only way that i'm able to
do this the other ways with the sponsors
so i'm
super super grateful for the sponsors
and for
and for the patrons people who donate
out of the kindness generosity
of their own heart
when they have
when there's no
obligation to do so it's incentive-free
there is one tier
so when i say it's incentive free that
is to say you don't get any
special invites on patreon you don't get
any special access on patreon
there is one tier though a meta field
theorist here which just opened up about
a month ago
where you can speak to myself for about
an hour or so along with others who are
on the group call it's limited to about
six people and people seem to have
enjoyed it for the previous one for an
additional benefit that i didn't foresee
which is networking
someone recently wanted some metal
printing done and someone else there was
in that field and someone wanted help
getting his toe more known and someone
said that they knew how to
pair silicon valley investors up with
people who are interested in having
their toe or sorry having some personal
intellectual endeavor conducted there's
someone who i think about
every once in a while his name is
voltaire i don't think i've ever
mentioned him on the podcast and
voltaire had a phrase where he said that
he has made himself dip he's made
himself dependent in order to become
independent and i feel like that's a
great way of summarizing what patreon is
the reason i'm mentioning it here is
because many people who are on the
who our patrons have said they would
never have known about it had i not
mentioned it and i remember saying i
mentioned in virtually every episode
they say oh i just i've listened to you
for a year and i haven't heard it until
just yesterday well that's because many
people skipped the intros so i'm
i'm deeply grateful i view it like
busking it's a shameful plug you know
people say this is a shameless plug and
so on i feel some shame it's
embarrassing
though i tend to view it like busking
where the podcast is be is able to be
enjoyed entirely for free
like a musical performance or a magic
trick except it's a podcast in this case
and then you choose to pay in fact it's
even more anonymous than busking because
you don't have the added social pressure
of people around you and then the end
where everyone claps and you have to
awkwardly walk away there's no
obligation even here this comes with a
time stamp somewhere where you can skip
this whole spiel because
i feel like the
firstly i don't like to be talked to in
this manner when it comes to someone
advertising the ways to support them or
sponsors and so on and all of these come
with a timestamp somewhere here or here
where they say you can skip this
introduction
or sponsor message because
well i don't want to force or trick
anyone into listening to what they
didn't intend to listen to and what that
does is it
radically reduces the amount that a
sponsor is willing to pay
and the amount that people would sign up
to patreon because like i mentioned
someone has
watched for a year and then had no idea
that i even had a patreon but i feel
like in the long run the trust that's
engendered by
putting up a timestamp or a method for
you to click out of this such that you
don't feel manipulated into listening to
something you didn't want to
that that will lead to a better
relationship with
with you with the people who are
watching with the patrons and with the
sponsors so in the short run it's not
it's not terribly great monetarily but
hopefully in the long run it is and my
wife my wife is extremely grateful for
all the support she is more grateful in
many ways than i am and that's saying
plenty so if you're
supporting or not just by watching thank
you i i appreciate your eyes i
appreciate whatever
it's
it's i'm in an extremely blessed
position so thank you as for the sponsor
today's sponsor is brilliant and
brilliant like i mentioned before
brilliance is a place that you can go to
to view
interactive learning experiences on
statistics and mathematics and physics
you can learn about group theory you can
learn about entropy i
over the winter break the 2021 december
2022 january was studying about entropy
because i wanted to learn why is it that
the formula for entropy is written in
this manner and
it becomes extremely clear extremely
lucid and perspicuous why s equals lawn
or log of the amount of states is an
extremely natural
way of
categorizing the information held in a
system and that it would be strange to
define it in any other manner
that comes from brilliant that my
knowledge of that comes from brilliance
and that's going to help me when i
eventually get to speak to chiara
marletto or david deutsch on their
constructor theory so visit
brilliant.org toe to get 20 off your
annual subscription
moses patunikos says do you prefer
burger king to kentucky i
i'm i much prefer burger king i actually
well it's just that kentucky fried
chicken is a bit too expensive for my
taste dustin hutchinson says if you were
me what question would you ask
well i think i would ask that question
dustin
that perhaps keeps in the theme of your
image
of the picture of a snake eating itself
jim morrison says how do you have under
5 000 twitter followers but
over 100 000 youtube subscribers can you
make it less obvious that you've
purchased subscribers so none of
twitter followers were purchased none of
the youtube subscribers were purchased i
don't
i just don't tweet so or if i do it's
primarily requests for information or
promotion for toe
i'm not terribly interesting on twitter
if you want to follow with that ringing
endorsement then it's at toe with kurt
and you can also see that there's
someone like arvin ash who has i think
over 600 000 subscribers and then less
than on youtube and then less than 10
000 on twitter grant sanderson has
millions and millions of youtube
subscribers but
far less a tenth less on twitter this is
just
par for the course if your main bread
and butter is youtube
i i don't imagine why your twitter
should be anywhere comparable
ah and many others have thought have
asked what are your thoughts on extra
dimensions
so i'm interested in
in
in how much of the fuss in physics is
about higher dimensions and then
compactifying it reducing it to the four
that we see in order to explain
observations i think it's much more
interesting to start with a lower
dimensional space and then build up to a
four-dimensional space
holography is one method by the way
because you have at least one dimension
down at a boundary and notice i said
that i find it interesting and
interesting is not a synonym for
for correctness it's just a subjective
guide that
occasionally leads you to a place of
importance
once explored rigorously and then seeing
if it has any connections to what we
eventually think of as a
correct path that's physics and math or
pure math in a nutshell one explores
purely out of interest
and then
hopefully later
some future mathematician or future
physicist will find use in it this
happens so often that it's
difficult to find exceptions to it rock
thompson says with regard to your
conversation with
luis alessando do you think
it's more of what he has seen and not
able to speak fully open about it
so
rock i don't understand the question
unfortunately and i
i do think he's seen plenty that he
can't talk about if that's what you're
referring to
i tactician hd i'm genuinely curious why
it's
why uaps accelerate so fast and why it's
not followed by a sonic boom so i don't
know as well that's
one of the mysteries
it may be a manipulation of space-time
or plasma or some other atypical effect
i'm unsure
alexandra gagne says art of endless he's
an architect right now that's a
reference to when i say or when i have
said
type in art vandaly in the beginning of
one of the episodes and it's a seinfeld
reference scott hernandez says kurt i'm
wondering
i hope you're not offended by this
question are you on the spectrum
and
and you strike me as someone who might
be i am glad to see your show is doing
well i wish you
success
so technically scott everyone is on the
spectrum though i'm not
diagnosed with even a scintilla of
asperger's or autism or whatever
is close to that i do have adhd to an
unbelievable degree that's certainly
true
if my
style of speech or delivery is staccato
it's generally because i
tend to think
extremely carefully about what i'm
saying and i try to match what i'm
saying with what's
intended and i try to
say it in a new manner
at least frequently and i try to not
repeat what other people have said and i
try to determine if what i'm saying is
someone else's speech or someone else's
thoughts
rather than my own so it's it's an
extremely difficult
process to
to extemporize
and also keep in mind that i'm severely
nervous when doing podcasts
don't mistake the uneasiness and stage
fright
for someone being on the spectrum
stephen paul king says do you have any
any thoughts on constructor theory not
yet
means of savagery
kurt have you ever considered getting
help with your editing
well
plenty of people have said that they
would do it for free but then they don't
and plenty of people said yeah kurt i'll
help you with transcribing for free but
then they don't often volunteers aren't
the most reliable source right now i'm
lucky enough to be able to
afford someone who can do at least the
preliminary edit and that's due to the
patrons like i mentioned before it's
extremely tricky
to get help with the channel in other
domains because
what i'm doing is it's not something
that's been attempted before and it's
not something that i can state in an
unblurred manner like in a limited
manner so for example there's a toe
manual sorry there's a yes that's right
there's a tome coming up
a manual of all the toes and
i i can't imagine someone helping me
with that it's extremely difficult
because toe is a personal quest like i
mentioned distilling it down to what i
think is a proper form for someone to be
able to understand a particular toe each
toe let's say has a page long dedicated
to it that's
not simple and what someone else thinks
is obvious may not be obvious to me and
what i think is is clear that it should
be included as an ingredient in such a
page may not be clear to someone else
there's too much back and forth
there's another project that there are
two other projects that i have that i
are about integrating physics and
consciousness and even ufos but i can't
announce that currently left blank says
i wanted to ask if you've taken any
psychedelics and would you consider dmt
i would definitely not take any dmt
anytime in the near or medium
future raw dog says i watched there will
be blood for the first time because you
mentioned it it's a great film what did
you like about it
i like the cinematography
i have a particularly keen eye for shot
composition
and a particular taste when it comes to
that for example i like
long drawn out shots that are
meticulously planned i like that there
was zero of a plot line regarding
love
or some romantic interest and that's
extremely extremely rare you'll notice
that virtually every movie has a
romantic interest sub line subplot
i also like the grittiness the
seriousness i like films that are
different in some major manner i like
the writing as well i have a keen ear
for dialogue that's
quote unquote lame or cringe-worthy or
artificial it stands out to me in the
same way that a a glitch may stand out
to someone who
plays a video game and i've heard many
video game reviewers say they don't like
the glitches in
let's say fallout or some of the
bethesda titles because it breaks
chronicle breaks the illusion of the
game i don't personally get absorbed in
video games like that enough for it to
break because i always feel like i know
that i'm playing a game it's obvious to
me if there's a glitch well that's just
par for the course of a video game
however when there's
feeble dialogue in a movie i can't help
but notice that i notice it like this it
just stands out to me just as much as i
imagine a glitch in a video game stands
out to
the people who feel like they're
absorbed in the video game easter beast
says is there an email address where i
can ask
a question about something i experienced
please
please easter beast
please no i
firstly i don't i don't know if i can
handle hearing about other people's
experiences secondly i don't want to be
in the possession of special knowledge
that i can't share i'm not interested in
classified information i don't want to
be in a position where i can't speak
with candor or i may need to be
i may need to compromise by speaking
expediently or dissimulating
and i can't
handle to be quite frank i can't handle
when people are discounting at length to
me about what they've gone through or
their advice for me
and i just use the word frank so frank
yang has done something similar and
frank by the way i am sorry frank i'm
sorry i know you've sent me a quite
lengthy email response i'm not
healthy enough right now to look at it
without being provoked and triggered i'm
slowly getting there slowly slowly
getting there thank the
heavens thank the lord think
well
thank you
i i appreciate the effusive response
frank and others
and i
apologize that i'm not able to respond
more quickly many people have sent words
of encouragement and instruction and
often they're contingent on some
worldview that's metaphysical or
or this or from people who consider
themselves to be enlightened self-titled
as enlightened and i hope you
you forgive me that i haven't responded
to you i'm just not at the place where i
can begin to read those comments and
personally i don't understand how
someone can
study
physics or
let's see let's say metaphysics and
consciousness and ufos and what it means
to have an identity and the self and so
on and not go through totalizing
horror to me it just means that they
haven't thought deeply enough about it
or that they haven't thought severely
enough about it or genuinely enough
about it or intensely enough about it
i feel like if one hasn't found a truth
that they
haven't recoiled from in horror
then perhaps one hasn't searched
enough
one has almost
no clue almost no clue as to how
much this
path that
one is on has been trodden
by millions and millions and
trillions billions
of
people
entities
objects before you and the aid you
in your healthy
pursual of some hypothetical claim and
you think well hey i'm just i'm truly
contending with this i don't think you
are i don't i don't think i was until i
well i'm speaking so vaguely around this
because
it's difficult to but
i think that if one
hasn't
shuddered and thought
that oh my gosh this can't be no no no
no
then
one
thinks that they're
or that one is deluding themselves into
thinking they're
rolling in the deep but they're
merely an ant on the surface
i'm speaking again from personal
experience thinking that what i was
doing was intense investigations
into reality but i was just
performing negligible scratches on the
surface
our
mt or mt says i'm late to the party but
i hope you read this kurt have you
watched pro wrestling
no
i've seen images videos and so on but i
don't watch it i
i'm not interested in that it sounds
interesting though i think you like it
and i'm glad that you do marky the
sparky says really enjoying the podcast
just one question why do we assume ufos
are from outer space that's correct
marky one should perhaps not assume that
craig fleming says get him on your show
steven greer labrad pam says have you
thought about steven greer as a guest
silver platter says what's your take on
stephen greer and zz koh says hi kurt
thanks for your work what are your
thoughts on stephen greer so
i have emailed stephen and steven's
people
particularly this one lady named anna
kramer who serves as his assistant i've
emailed her
approximately once a month for the past
year or year and a half or so and she
has said
every single time no steven will not
come on i
i don't know why because i haven't had
someone say no
so consistently ever for any interview
that i've done whether it's with my
previous company indie film to or as a
filmmaker in some other film or toe or
or any other any other venture in my
life i don't think i've had someone say
no so many times
without saying yes
the
public email for anna is anna kramer at
siriusdisclosure.com i will put that in
the email address the reason why sorry
i'll put that in the description the
reason why i'm saying that out loud is
because it's a public email and i think
that if you who's listening would
request
i would love to see steven grier on the
toe podcast on the theories of
everything podcast with kurt can you
please have him come on i would love to
see that if you email and say that that
would increase the chances
sure basher says in biblical times they
said that angels came from the heavens
of
on chariots of fire do you think that
ufos could be angels or the workings of
god i think that the epilogue that the
current phenomenon served as an
inspiration for
ancient hierophany is
not terribly strong i know many people
love that
proposition or that hypothesis i'm not
terribly convinced
it's tied to religion in the form of
of being a scaffolding or an instigation
of
all of religion or all of major religion
to me is
it's contradictory and it can't be the
full account it's
could possibly be a partial account
rajiro bahiro says good evening kurt
concerning ufos are you now a believer
after all the interviews you've done are
you still skeptic are you a skeptic and
why and so on things from canada cool
i'm an inquisitor i'm unsure
what is occurring it feels like
something is amiss
i don't see it as being
obviously terrine or non-terrain
and i am certainly not a skeptic
i'm a curious person dean colby says
what are your three favorite novels
i
i don't have
more than one favorite book and that's
gerda escherbach i don't think i have a
second
i do have
two books that i frequently and only
recommend on this channel i think
there's only been two books by people
who are living sorry by people who have
been on the
toe channel that's carlo rivelli's the
order of time i believe it's called and
then another is
ian mcgill chris master and his emissary
i thoroughly thoroughly enjoyed those
books i also love girdle escherbach
douglas hofstadter hasn't been on the
program so i don't include him in that
but i recommend that wholeheartedly
matthew wallace says hello kurt how do
you avoid existential dread
barely
matthew though i'm i'm thinking of doing
a standalone podcast on
the dark knight of the soul much like
how i read jacob smallian's
god is a taoist which is one of my
favorite pieces on this channel it's the
musings of a mathematician on free will
from a zen perspective
couched in the chronicle of a man
speaking to god begging god to release
him from the burden of free will just me
thinking about doing a reading of the
dark knight of a soul sorry the dark
knight of the soul and doing some
commentary on it
it provokes me slightly
it agitates me and i think that that may
be a reason why i should
do it as a form of therapy for myself
and perhaps
hopefully others it may quell my own
existential dread recontextualize it to
not be so terrifying and debilitating
i've also talked about the dark knight
of the soul on the diana pasulka podcast
which will be around here and the chloe
valdari podcast in some ways it's about
ego death
though perhaps the term ego death should
be ego transformation or liberation or
metamorphism or integration because it
can feel like dying but
i don't think ego death is the right
term i think it's a
well it's a provocative term
there's light though there's wonderful
beams of light of
a wonderful wondrous
beneficent beatific place
of of goodness
that can come from it
as
a
a place that's
that's helpful and
and supporting and shielding and
generous
and tranquil
and calming and loving
so i don't know if ego death is the
right
term i would prefer to
have a different terminology i feel like
my issue with
with toe what's happened is that i've
been
hypothesizing and hypothetizing
far too much
it's
it's a huge huge huge cognitive
effort sorry it's a huge imposition in
some ways to go through someone's toe
and then jump to another one and then
jump to another one and jump to another
one it's extremely
psychologically
unsettling like that's to say the least
it's unsettling
it's
something that i thinking about toes and
thinking about
how to make sense of certain facts and
not even facts how to make sense of what
it means to make sense is something that
consumes me unceasingly virtually every
single minute
of
every waking day for the past few months
and by the way sometimes even the
sleeping days that that is to say not
just in my wakeful moments but when i
sleep though i love it i don't i
actually like nightmares i rarely get
them but i
i have a perverse relationship to
nightmares because i believe that
they're regenerative in some manner that
i'm facing a fear and hey i would much
rather face it there than face it in a
in the waking life i used to believe
that people who say you should be
open-minded but not so open-minded that
your head falls out
i used to feel like they betray a
certain idea of god because what they're
doing is
following not following truth they're
following what it means to survive and
to put their health above
objective truth or something higher than
themselves
that is to say how do you know you
crossed a line
until you've crossed it even even then
you don't know because many people who
have gone mad quote unquote don't
believe themselves to be mad and it's
difficult to know when one's head has
fallen out but i see the utility in that
phrase and i never saw it before i used
to see that as being a
statement that's less about searching
for the truth and more about justifying
the perimeter of lines that you've
already established shouldn't be crossed
so it's a statement of anti-truth but
now i see that there's there's ex there
well
there's extreme danger what it feels
like to awaken if that's even what it
what is the case is it's
it's like uh
at least now it feels like i'm in a daze
i mean i'm i'm i'm sleeping
while i'm awake it's it's at least not
horrific anymore there are moments of
lucidity which happen more and more and
more frequently think
thank god thank the universe think
whatever it may be
i feel much more grounded i feel more
eagerly sorry my ego feels more grounded
and it's extremely pleasant and now i've
come to the
conclusion that perhaps one shouldn't
have an open mind necessarily one should
have an open heart but that's not the
same as an open mind an open heart comes
first
i don't think that the terror is worth
the trade
i think that love should be primary
and i hope that
i hope that
well
well i hope i hope what i hope for i
don't know
james robert ryan says kurt you're far
too hard on yourself please stop you're
a beautiful
human soul
mobsta imaging says
i have yet to catch the full episode
with diana yet i can see that you're
struggling and i would suggest that you
don't be too hard on yourself your
insane attempt to
try and comprehend everything in the way
that you do
by going into minutia and mathematics
and physics and so on is
is putting yourself under constant
stress
of of sitting in endless
exams where you're cramming for studying
without break
mobster imaging i
used to be extremely hard on myself i
still am in many respects but i've
slowly come to appreciate
that
what i'm
or what is being done with the toe
channel is is a is it
well firstly i've forgotten almost all
of my university studies which means i'm
starting from scratch so i've had to
build up essentially a phd level
understanding of different fields
when i say it's almost like it is
because technically as a phd in a
postdoc you have to do research so
it's an unqualified statement when i say
that
it's at the phd level
hopefully that makes sense but i've come
to now appreciate that
this is an extremely difficult endeavor
because of that reason and and i have to
do so while i'm not at my cognitive
optimal firstly age-wise secondly
i'm well recent
events
wise
and i'm studying completely alone having
almost no one to ask for clarification
here and there and then number four i'm
building the theories of everything
channel in different directions
simultaneously emailing guests and so on
booking and editing and number five i'm
i'm studying
much more than mathematics and physics
i'm studying neuroscience and philosophy
and religion metaphysics
and i have to do this all while still
being able to spend time with my wife
and while being able to keep my body
extremely fit which i prioritize my
health and and my relationship and while
being interviewed on other platforms
like previously just about two hours or
three hours ago i was on greg henriques
and generation zed a few hours prior to
that and chris leto was coming up
coleman hughes is coming up and i have
to do that while not knowing what the
heck am i doing i'm learning all of this
as i go there's no straight and narrow
list of courses in order
to
to get a degree in the subject of toes
and
at the same time i'm doing that while i
have a non-profit film company on the
side running a film festival and
then at the same time i'm doing that
while
not having someone to carry me like eric
weinstein did for lex or or rogan did
for lex or
to have
personal connections to people like how
put off like i know some youtubers do
and they say yeah i'm friends with him
and i've talked with them so i have some
bitterness and self-loathing there i i
do i see it i
i just remind myself look kurt you're
doing all of this all of what i've
listed simultaneously virtually
by myself and luckily now i have the
help of my wife who essentially
who's like a partner in tow and she
she does she helps me with the comments
and with the direction of toe and now
i'm luckily able to hire an editor for
tow so
i have to remind myself that it's an
extremely heavy heavy heavy heavy load
i still feel if i'm being honest
that i i'm not making enough progress
i'm extremely far behind i often feel i
often tell myself i'm 15 years behind i
feel like my mind is 15 years too late
15 years over and over that i'm not
learning quick enough i'm i get
extremely annoyed when i have to relearn
material that i should have absorbed the
first time 15 years ago
but at the same time it's it's it's just
it's
it's not something that's been attempted
at least not publicly i don't i don't
know
so
i can give myself some slack it's
difficult though because i feel like
when i'm
i it's difficult for me to pat myself on
the back i feel like i'm giving myself a
way out so self-love is something that i
have a
difficult time with i'm getting much
better with that though i'm much better
with that than i've ever been
i'm nowhere near optimal
andreas muller says a german here you
firstly your pronunciation of veltan
xiaomi is terrible and cute secondly
why is it so important for you to find a
veltan xiaolong what i admire
about you is that you remain critical
and open but after so many guests all
lying to themselves surely you have
realized that the quest is pointless
even if you disagree what would the
consequence be if you agreed with me so
firstly let's spell out what a veltan
showing is that's like an
all-encompassing world view
such that you can contextualize or
interpolate novel pieces of information
you can acquire new knowledge quickly
because you have a model that's already
been formed and this view usually has
something to do with ontology which is
metaphysics and
and then you live in a way that
that comports with that so some people
they live in a way that's
that's self sorry that's hypocritical
but
i consider someone who has a veltan
showing to be consistent with their
professed beliefs
and the model generally has a built-in
mechanism for updating its own model so
that's a a meta model
all lying to themselves surely you've
realized the quest is pointless
so there's some
i have intimations occasionally of a
twin wittgenstein who's a philosopher of
the 1900s and heidegger who's also a
philosopher of the 1900s continental and
analytical
that
i have intimations that there is no
point to talking that this is all fruit
fruitless and futile and
language is a is a problem so some
people would take the approach and say
okay so then
let's stop talking but heidegger takes
the approach and says that
it means that we need to develop a new
language the current language is the
problem much like
if one was trying to do mathematics
without algebra which was the case
thousands of years ago you're severely
limited in what you could do essentially
you could just do euclidean geometry and
not even topology so topology is
geometric but you need open sets so you
need to have an algebraic
conception to understand topology
properly
and
otherwise you can just do so purely
visually but then you miss certain
aspects of topology you can't do physics
precisely either so imagine you go back
3000 years ago and you say that language
is the problem and only experience can
tell you the laws of physics but then
you would completely miss that
experience is extremely misleading when
it comes to seeing regularities of
nature and laws and so on there are
plenty of counter-intuitive results and
that's leaving quantum mechanics
out of this it seems extremely clear
that there are entire frameworks
and world views and
and models that that are in principle
out of reach from one's current position
however acquiring some new psycho
technology quote unquote allows for some
radical change
and this is a term from john vervecki a
way to think about this is imagine if
imagine all of the concepts you can you
can't have let alone explain
if
all that was taken from you were
well if every single word was taken from
you except ten so you could only express
ten words then would you say well these
concepts are in principle out of reach
maybe you would say so but it would be
false because it just requires an
explication of language a delineation of
language a more specific language so
then you can think of that in an
interesting manner what the heck is the
toe project well it's an attempt to
build psychotechnologies there's that
word against psychotechnologies to
bridge the gap between the east and the
west which currently is
currently seems unbridgeable
according to many people
and perhaps even some orthogonal view
it's not just east and west perhaps
there's a third perhaps there's a fourth
so an attempt to bridge some
communication between them to merge them
abby genosis like call this occasionally
such that we can
hopefully understand
the
the world
this is
tricky to say because
there are many assumptions that go in
this but
let me just speak around this such that
we can understand the world and
ourselves
better is the word that comes to mind
but it's false it's not better
accurate it may not even be the
correct word here but hopefully you
understand what i'm trying to convey
sebastian mahler says
how do you have such white teeth
tips beautiful looking hair as well i
also like the
frowning look
pretty good podcast also good day well
hey man
sebastian thank you
chase says
do you know the subset scores of your iq
verbal versus non-iq i believe i talked
about iq on the first podcast as for the
subset the verbal i believe was far
lower than the analytical or the
mathematical component mark eirardo says
what brand or model of the guitar is
there behind the wall it's just a simple
epiphone i believe it's called and i get
questions about this guitar people want
to hear me play i sing and play
i wouldn't imagine it's terribly great i
sing mainly 90s songs i
i would love to record a cover song or
two but my wife is adamantly against it
because she feels
probably accurately so that i'll
embarrass myself and it's also
self-aggrandizing at least it would be
in my case
if you want to see another side of me an
artistic side though this one is on the
comedic end then perhaps watch the april
fools video particularly number two
which is here the the ranking of the
toes that's what it's called and i do
essentially stand up there because i
used to do stand-up when i was younger
charles gervais says hey kurt what's the
best way to stay up to date with the
latest articles within one's desired
field what are the best journals and so
on
that's
charles that's extremely field dependent
i don't know much
out of a narrow focus of high energy
physics and even there i know almost i'd
say almost nothing there's several
subfields
you can be at the top of
string theory and know virtually nothing
about the developments in your closest
competitor loop quantum gravity and this
was evidence when david gross spoke to
carla rivelli
philip o says
did you say that you want to interview
lester out someday or did i dream that
ah that would be an epic crossover i'm a
huge fan of him since i was a
child i did an interview philip with les
and i'll put the link in the description
also put a thumbnail here
chase says curt have you considered your
inability to leave your mind and attend
to the things around you that is less of
a left brain issue and perhaps an issue
to be fleshed out in in therapy and
psychoanalysis
do you reckon this is just your nature
i am able to leave my mind
now occasionally it happens it's rare it
happens more often
more and more often
willfully
and
sometimes even without will then well
i'm considering many options tiffany
says tiffany curly says do we require a
new religion to get us through the
current storm
or perhaps tiffany and
a new look at existing religion
moses says my question
and this is a profound one why do you
have the same voice as tom cruise
now that's a first
moses
debboni debody says kurt on the ama can
you do a little digging on google about
creating a time crystal
a new phase of matter has been
discovered and newton's second law is
now destroyed compelling and so on
i i haven't looked into that
i tend to not look into what's
in the news scientifically like
scientific america
because
there are
on a weekly basis some
announcements about a large physical
breakthrough or some new measurement of
some mass of some particle and it breaks
all the laws
and
then when one looks into the result or
the results been replicated if
with more accuracy the discrepancy goes
away
because of this i don't pay much
attention to what's occurring and i have
plenty on my plate already there are
plenty of
puzzles with the existing paradigms
number two says when are you going to
interview daniel
diana pasulka i've already done so and
again thumbnail here
and i'll just read from the description
that i that i wrote for diana pasulka
the recent interview with diana is one
that i'm particularly proud of why
broadly speaking there are two subsets
of the toe audience those interested
heavily in the philosophical material
physics b
those interested in the ufo oriented
content
while these groups
overlap substantially what's distinct
about the diana episode is that it
merges both perspicuously and
beautifully in fact i blatantly didn't
put a ufo tag in the title or the
thumbnail if you're interested in
religion and philosophy then this deep
dive is one of the best on toe for
audience a that is the
philosophical physics related
subset while showing how it intersects
with the quote-unquote phenomenon which
is aligned with audience b this will
introduce new topics and models of
thinking to each group though again a
and b are not mutually exclusive
the conversation with diana was filled
with such mutual respect and love akin
to the carlo revelli episode especially
when we were gushing over heidegger i
see the toe project as an extension of
heidegger's main themes and i consider
him to be a row what is a row
it's an internal name i have i actually
haven't said this
allowed yet
it's an internal name that's false i
mean
i've said it aloud it hasn't been
published
it's an internal name that i have for
resiners of existence which i'll expand
upon more in an upcoming ama which is
this i'll do so shortly
it's a name that i have for the types of
people who are trying to understand
reality who don't scorn other approaches
like secular or religion or religious
traditions they include yoshibak
castro
levin donald hoffman and so on and so on
okay so rezner what is a rezner it's a
french term and it's a term of art
which means the person who voices the
central theme philosophy or point of
view of a work of
of
well of a piece of work
generally you see this in movies when
someone toward the end of the film
encapsulates what the
motif was of the film or the point of
the film was
and does so beautifully they often do so
as if they're speaking to another
character but you can tell it's it's
exposition for us as the audience
members passively viewing it
if it's written well it wouldn't seem
like that
so
why do i call them resinors of existence
well one can think of this like a play
in some sense the story of life
and
i feel like there
aren't many people who are
deeply wrestling or contending with what
existence is because most academics feel
like well
it's ill-defined it's nebulous you
shouldn't even think about it if it's if
it's unclear what it means
but yet there are people like yoshibak
and
bernardo castro and donald hoffman and
roger penrose and carl fristen and john
verveicky and greg henriques who are
i'd say they're investigating
fundamental reality from an
extremely originative perspective they
don't have a disdain for non-secular
spirituality which is also rare they
have developed their point of view
pretty much singularly and they also
have a flare for rigor so that's the
four conditions that i have for a row
another way that i think about it is in
mathematics there's something called
associativity so there's commutativity
i'm sure you've heard of x times y is
not the same as y times x always when
they are they're commutative then
there's associativity which which has to
do with placing brackets around
the objects and saying that you can
place brackets anywhere so
as an aside chris fields believes that
because quantum mechanics has
associativity in it it implies that
observers and self and so on are
illusory or could be made to be
could be made to have flexible
boundaries but that's
that's not always true there are
formulations of quantum mechanics and
their unifications of quantum mechanics
and general relativity which are based
in the octonions which are
non-associative so you can't place the
brackets anywhere a times b bracketed
times c is not the same as
a bracket b times c bracket close
bracket i'm speaking to someone shortly
named to jinder singh who has an octonic
metal matter sorry
has an octanic
model of the
of unification
regardless the point of this was to make
the analogy that i view the
rose the resiners of existence as a
non-associative philosophical rat pack
and
it's complicated to
to explain more about what that means so
hopefully
this little
teaser has
has done so
oftentimes people ask me
hey you should interview this person or
this person and and sure the choices in
my head come down to yes they have a toe
but are they a row
perhaps no
boris costello says haha man i'd love to
know how you get such
a rich vocabulary coming from math and
physics
i i don't boris thank you i'm constantly
struggling i appreciate the compliment
it's undeserved
i
i don't
personally i don't understand how people
can live stream this is extremely
intimidating
it's it requires an extreme amount of
courage to extemporize unfettered in an
unfettered manner that either people who
live stream are either greatly skilled
or they have
huge amounts of hearty hood
courage valor and so on or they are
or i'm greatly unskilled or
or
they're saying someone else's thoughts
and it's and the reason i say that is
because it's extremely extremely
difficult to think for oneself it's
extremely difficult it takes me
me
for instance many minutes to articulate
sometimes a single thought that i feel
like is my own
by the way boris is
someone that who
has been a fan of the theories of
everything channel for a while and then
messaged me on
messaged me and said hey kurt i would
love to invite you out to
to montreal and take
photos
of you because i'm a cg artist and i do
compositing and here's some of my work
and i looked at it and it was
absolutely gorgeous
and here's his instagram for people who
would like to use boris for their
upcoming shoots
he has worked on marvel films and star
wars films and continues to do so his
instagram is at gaelic pic so that is at
g-a-l-a-c-p-i-c
and his linkedin will be put in the
description as well i recommend you
subscribe or
follow i'm unsure of how instagram works
what the terminology is
his work because it's
it's
it's unparalleled
graphic design and photography it's a
combination of both
thank you again boris it was great to
meet you and
soon those photos will come onto the tow
channel and i'll place them somewhere
maybe i'll do a special video about them
crescendo boss says when are you
interviewing chiara marletto so whenever
she responds to my emails and again
similarly to anna cramer for stephen
greer feel free to email chara
and let her know that
hey perhaps you should come on the tow
channel it would be great i would love
to see you there every email to someone
else does help because often mine either
goes to spam or they're flooded with
many requests that they have to see it
repeated in order for them to feel like
it's worth it
mr rahman says how difficult is it for
you to manage remaining true to the
original idea of toe meaning having
guests
meaning having guests who are scientists
and mathematicians or the top rated
videos of the study of ufo phenomenon
there's an obvious monetary difference
with these as well
i found your channel
i found your channel solely because of
the uap studies i imagine that this is a
struggle for a successful
youtuber such as yourself
well
mr rahman thank you for
i appreciate you calling me successful
that it doesn't feel like it but i
appreciate
i appreciate that it i come across as
that or
whatever it may be it's false to think
that there's more money
in the ufo
topic
actually there's
far more money in
the topics of well i in two more topics
that i won't say
in fact i've been offered money to
interview people
and i don't
in at least one of the cases where
someone has offered me money it's it was
more money than i had made at
in my entire life for any single year
it's more money than any
single year of my annual income
at least up until that point and i was
fairly recently
and i choose not to do so it took almost
everything for me i remember debating it
for for weeks and weeks with my wife
should i do so but it just felt
incorrect to go down a route purely for
the money it's another reason why i say
and i'm like i'm pretending this is all
selfless it's not it's
it's hopefully what i'm doing is for the
long term so it's selfish in the sense
that i think it's better in the long run
but like i mentioned there's time stamps
the reason is that i feel like
building
a great relationship with the audience
and being authentic and ingenuous in the
long run will be
what serves the quote-unquote success
that you refer to earlier
saying being true to the original idea
of the toe that's an interesting way of
of
of putting it because what's the
original idea of the toe but to
understand sorry the toe channel but to
understand the universe almost each
scientist would agree that finding life
like microbial life would be one of the
most groundbreaking
discoveries of the entire
of of humanity
and that's just microbial single-celled
life what if something more drastic is
occurring far closer what would the
implications be for how we understand
ourselves what about for physics what
about for philosophy
is if that's not aligned with toe then
i'm unsure what's aligned with toe we
may have different ideas as to what it
as to what the greatest mysteries in the
world may be and some people say like
diana pasulka i heard her say this and i
dislike this i i'm gonna have a little
bit of a bone to pick with her i mean
this gently diana if you're watching
this
she and someone like gary has also said
this too
she'll say something like okay i'll i'll
answer the following question but let me
do so as a
as a person rather than as a professor
and then she'll give some sweet generous
perspective
and the reason why i dislike that is
because
ostensibly the
well they're afraid of having their wild
attitude taint them as a scholar but to
me
one's professorship their scholarship
entails that one should speak
honestly and not try to
just say what's in the
perimeter or the accepted boundaries of
discourse and they should allow
authentic speculation encourage it and
put oneself on the line with an
unorthodox view because you have tenure
for example and to play devil's advocate
to even the most untenable positions to
me that's what a professor should do so
when one then says well let me take off
my professor hat and put on the person
hat or the diana hat the regular gary
hat or whatever it may be to me that's
a relinquishing of what it means to be a
professor and i understand what they're
saying they don't want people to think
that they're speaking based on the
evidence that they've acquired during
their scholarly research but i also
think that it gives the wrong impression
of what i could of what the academy
should be about and then the question is
well to what extent does one speculate i
talk about this with
with
generation zed
that
while i talk about speculation and the
salutary components of speculation the
next question comes from ma7 can you do
a video where you distill
conclusions from all the interviews that
you've had by now i imagine that you've
been exposed to the most interesting
tools and have developed your own
maybe a reconciled version or or basic
outlines
so the crash course on physics which
somewhere is somewhere along here took a
huge amount of time to record and write
and i don't know when the
the next video is that i'll do akin to
that because i don't particularly like
lecturing or giving lessons and you're
asking me for what i've developed i'm i
i
i'm much more interested in pursuing
knowledge than i am of conveying
knowledge
even this ama by the way takes weeks and
weeks because i have to decock to my
thoughts and it means i have to wade
through
muck
much muck internally to cultivate an
articulated thought
dharma matar says have you tried getting
eric davis
for an interview yes i'm working on that
kenneth wilbur says
i wonder if that's
okay kurt what subject if any is
entirely untouched by the toe channel
would you like to discuss and why
so
i would like to discuss adhd and
learning because those are meta aspects
of a toe so some toes
people who have toes like to use the
word meta frequently
and i'd say that there's a meta meta toe
which is about learning the learning of
a toe
at least the more especially the more
physical toes and perhaps even the
experiential ones which need to be
well the experiential ones they say that
you need to learn and unlearn i love
this parable of i don't know if it comes
from lao tzu but someone said can you
teach me and then someone said sure i'll
teach you some zen master and he started
pouring tea and then the cup overfloweth
and kept overflowing
and the student
was saying at some point after like 10
minutes said what are you doing stop
you're spilling it everywhere and then
the
zen master said
that's like your mind
that you're coming to me to learn but
your cup is already filled
you need to unlearn come to me when your
mind is empty
so that's why i said that perhaps the
experiential approach is also about
unlearning as much as it's about
learning regardless this meta aspect of
learning of adhd and so on and the
practices that one can employ as someone
who's
learning challenged in this manner is
something that i would like to pursue on
the toe channel that i haven't this next
question comes from christoph benos is
there anything legitimate regarding ufos
any credible source
any links to anything tangible no of
course christos it depends on what one
means by ufo because plenty is
classified as
as such
i understand what you mean though and i
would say that there's
no
at least none not that's accessible to
the public there's nothing that is not
circumstantial evidence that the public
has access to to suggest that the
causal factors what's behind the ufos is
it's it's is entities it's precipitated
by something that far
escapes our current understanding or our
phylogenetic tree it's either not a part
of it or it's from some aspect of it
that we don't currently understand or
have
a conception of the circumstantial
evidence that does exist is plenty and i
would say that it's more so than
either amber heard or johnny depp had
against one another combined yet the
whole world seemed to have placed
themselves pertinaciously on one side of
the spectrum or one side of the aisle
there the world is a
at least
well the more one investigates it the
world is a place of
of paradoxical complexity
and the familiar is an aberration
and so i don't hold the view that
ill-defined and esoteric topics
should be
viewed upon or explored
with
scorn or derision
and
it took me
years and years and years to realize
that my criticism that i felt like was
dispassionate and purely from a rational
perspective was from a place of of
arrogance i thought it came from a place
of reasoning
building up from quote-unquote first
principles i believe myself to be
operating from such a place but i'm
deeply skeptical of people who
haven't realized that about themselves i
know from personal experience how
delusive it can be to think that one is
operating from a position of a rational
standpoint when
virtually all the evidence that we have
is that
all the psychological evidence we have
is that that's decidedly not the case
we're far more we care far more about
our position on a social echelon than we
do about almost anything else
and so
well
that was a tangent and i appreciate the
question christos
ali says what would be the
what would be your thoughts on
metaphysics in the means of chaos and
accidents oriented essence of reality we
face now
and how would you eliminate absurdities
of living and truth if we take them as
the case take nietzsche take nietzsche
as your rival i'm sorry ali i don't
understand the question avesta says hey
dude have you heard of the e8 model so
yes that's someone from that's someone
named garrett lisa's model and at some
point this year hopefully i will be
speaking to him perhaps around the same
time i get
the chance to take a look at geometric
unity julian weinstein weinstein
says to know that consciousness is
fundamental must want to experience this
directly is there any way to
through words or logic realize that
space time is not fundamental in other
and by the way about the
space time not being fundamental much
ado is made about that and either
excoriate excoriating or venerating
donald hoffman but the majority of
physicists don't believe space time to
be fundamental and it's also not that
outlandish to think so
okay lastly
what is required to grok this as an
altered state neural psychologically
neurophysiologically via psychoactive
substances and what does that say about
the causal power of the brain if
anything so i don't i don't know julian
i don't know the answer to your question
all i know is that the last sentence the
causal power of the brain has embedded
in it an assumption of what one is
is
is trying to prove or derive from that
point so that is assuming that the brain
is and is mind independent in some
manner than concluding mind independence
and all of this is a
place that all of this is a
decidedly difficult
treacherous domain because there are
enthymemes everywhere enthymemes being
these unstated assumptions that are so
embedded and subtle we don't realize
them that we've made them until years or
decades millennia later i believe many
many many of our philosophical problems
perhaps all of them are like that jojo
752 says kurt i've been following you
for a while now and i'm glad you've
gained such a following congrats hey
thank you joe
my question is
as someone that generally listens to the
podcast not youtube is there any
chance you could have an email that
accompanies your interviews with slides
there's a collective attempt right now
on the discord so i'll place a link to
the discord somewhere
where people are making notes show notes
for every episode meticulous
meticulously i'm meticulously timestamp
they meticulously summate particularly
this person named or this user named
timecake i'll leave a link to all of
that in the description curb killer says
what would you ask uh extra
extraterrestrial being as a first
question
if you were the first to get an
interview
i don't know if i had one question
that's a bit too much pressure curb
killers i need to think about that some
more vincent marone said would you ever
consider taking your show on the road
now a live show a podcast a panel with
guests and
and a stage and so on that's in the
works i'm their plans exciting plans for
2022 like i mentioned especially 2023.
this next question says how would the
academic community react
to uaps being real if they were revealed
to be
well i think they would do so
with
i think that
they would have an initial disbelief and
then arrogance that uaps are obviously
quote-unquote real
and
they would lack any
reference to their previously
derogatory attitude
and
have no remorseful or little remorseful
recognition
for
those that they've contempt along the
way i don't have a username for you i'm
sorry but i think that they'll dismiss
they'll cavalierly dismiss those that
have believed in ufos prior to the
evidence quote-unquote being revealed as
hey you should only follow the evidence
and so they'll be further cemented the
the rationalists let's say i i don't
know what else to call them the neil
degrasse tysons i don't mean to pick on
neil i'm just
i'm using him as an idol for the as a
representation of
the
i don't know what to call it other than
the rationalist or the neil degrasse
tysons that they'll be further
entrenched in their view that hey well
now we just follow the evidence and it
doesn't matter that millions upon
millions of people had experiences with
these they had they had
great intuition sure but that needs to
be followed with a different with with
evidence and so on
i don't think there would be any
apology i don't think that there would
be any less disparagement i think that
the ufo community will get almost no
credit for being right about something
so
so obtuse in the sense that it's so
unlikely at least with our current
paradigm
how the heck could you be so likely how
the heck could you follow something and
be so correct for so long without
meaning that there's something true
about the intuition that you've followed
or the experiences that you've had and
perhaps that means the scientific
community needs to expand what they
consider to be evidence or at least
expand what they consider to be
evidence for avenues for further
exploration of a different kind of
evidence concrete evidence and so on
well
stefan says would you like a cup of tea
i have mine here i appreciate it stephen
it's cold now
extremely cold matriarch said how are
you
what are some of you the favorite things
that you've learned this past month
what makes these memorable to you
i love this question someone else wrote
as a comment and i hope that he starts
he referring to kurt i hope that kurt
starts
all his introductions like this
so
if you
if you ask people let's see matriarch
matriarch if you ask people let me see
if i can explain this
quickly because it's getting extremely
late here if you were to ask people
to take a die
so this is all i have right now take a
die imagine this is a six sided
cube
actually
this so take a die it's gonna keep
beeping and beeping imagine these so it
says number six up here in the number
one down here they always add up to
seven if you're unaware of that fact you
need to be aware of that so then five
here would be met with the two on the
other side because all the numbers add
up to seven that are on antipodal points
so then the
experimenter says to you look you're
going to roll this die it's going to
come up with some number let's say it
comes up with 5
on the top you can choose in your own
head you don't say it allowed which
number do you want the top or the bottom
so you're supposed to choose this prior
to rolling it but whatever one you
choose let's say you chose the top
number you get that amount of dollars so
in this case you roll five you're gonna
get five dollars if you had chosen the
bottom one remember this is a private
choice you just tell it to yourself then
you only get two dollars now how does
the investigator know or the
experimenter know which one you've
chosen up or down well you tell them
after it's been rolled
so you say
you roll it it lands a six on the top
and you say oh oh i
i meant to the top of course i'm at the
top they give you six dollars you then
roll it again you get a a four on the
top and a
three on the bottom and then you say yes
again i meant the top like i chose top
they give you four dollars you roll it
and then it gets a two on the top then
you say in that case i meant of i meant
the bottom one like i you have no idea
you can't read my mind but i'm telling
you
i'm not lying to you it's the bottom one
that i chosen prior to this okay they
give they give you five dollars so what
happens
probably what you imagined to happen
which is that people cheat and the way
that you can analyze this without
reading someone's mind is at a
statistical average level that they tend
to earn more than they should if it was
statistically random and you can measure
how much they cheat by and you can also
measure that they cheat because they can
be
clamped down with a lie detect on a lie
detector test and you can see when
they're lying and now you say well let's
switch the test and let's say this money
that is going to be
awarded because you've rolled a die and
you've chosen internally up or down
prior to the roll this money is not
going to you any longer it's going to a
charity
so then the question is well what
happens does lying increase or decrease
so i thought about this and i thought
the lying would decrease
because
it's for charity so people feel more
moral and people would be aligned
hopefully aligned with the good and that
would remind them of
acting correctly however
it turns out
that they lie more
so
okay that's extremely interesting well
why well
because even though they're not
self-motivated they feel like hey i'm
doing something that's that's good i'm
lying for the greater good that's why i
think it's extremely dangerous to ever
to i think it's extremely dangerous to
lie especially when you think you're
conical lying for the greater good
because you'll fool yourself into
thinking that there's nothing wrong with
it and then
you'll make incremental steps in the
direction of
of
mendacity and dissimulation okay then
you wonder well what happens with the
lie detector
do they does it go off even more turns
out that the light detector can no
longer detect the lies
so that's extremely interesting why
because the lie detector doesn't detect
lies per se it detects tension so it
detects in the initial case that
let's say it's number three on the top
and four on the bottom and you had said
i'm gonna choose the top one before it
rolls it's three on the top then you're
like ah
i want four dollars i don't want three
dollars
there's a tension there where you're
like i want to be a good person but i
want four dollars at the same time so
that is what shows up on the lie
detector however if now you're lying
quote unquote for a charity there's no
tension you're doing what's right
this is one of the reasons why
sometimes people who
who lie
and well
people who lie can do so
so charismatically and so fluently and
and fluidly too
because
they believe they're doing so for some
greater cause and i'm i well i'm sure
you can imagine certain people doing
this but it's it's better to imagine
yourself doing this
oneself doing this
i think it's extremely dangerous to lie
in any small case and especially you'd
think no well the the edge cases where
one is doing it for
what's noble is the easiest case yes if
it's for the greater good you lie i
don't know i think that that's a
slippery path and it's a path where
you don't realize that you're doing it
and you have a grandiose vision of
yourself and you have no
no
dissonance associated with that so i
think it's extremely dangerous by the
way if you like
different formats if you have different
ideas for formats of toe
then
then please do let me know for example
some people have suggested that i end
each episode with my takeaways i'm not
going to do that but that's a possible
format another one is end it with a line
of poetry that you like or an equation
that you find particularly impactful if
you have ideas let me know dan ako says
what made what made you originally love
the
love physics so much and did you enjoy
physics as a kid
i like puzzles i like logical puzzles
and creative problem-solving puzzles and
by the way there are two ways of
attacking a theory or some puzzle so one
is to attack it at its root
and then the other is to
investigate what ramifies so the ramos
structure it's complex and baroque and
it's difficult
to reach unless you know how to climb
that tree which occurs after years and
years of
laborious
lucubration so alternatively one can
take an axe to the accessible trunk like
i mentioned that's the first one and
that's what you can do without ever
having to learn
the language or the consequences of the
of the
of the intricate implications the
process of
of toe is to attempt both okay i realize
i'm speaking a bit abstractly what i'm
saying is that
one can say in physics well look this is
not the correct molecule that one should
associate with some phenomenon okay
that's chemistry but then what you can
do is if you have no clue you can take a
post-modern approach and say hey you
shouldn't even be
relying on science to begin with
and then what you've done is
you've somehow answered that question
well does this molecule fit here or not
by attacking a much more fundamental
part and
it's actually the easy way out is to
attack the trunk and you'll see this
frequently in the comment sections of
other people's videos luckily the total
channel tends to have great comments so
not here but you'll see people say oh
well all of this is misguided don't they
see that numbers are are
an illusion and mathematics is so and so
well
you're on an edwitten video about the
modulized space of romanian manifolds
and then you say you have no clue what
that means so then you say yeah but it
must be false because look if
mathematics is the wrong approach to
begin to begin with so what one is doing
there is attacking the trunk and that's
a valid approach well perhaps it is
perhaps it isn't some people would argue
i would say that that's one approach and
then the other is to actually go in and
attempt to let's say navigate this the
modulized space of riemannian manifolds
and to formulate a theory sorry a
theorem and then prove it okay or
disprove it and that's difficult
extremely extremely extremely difficult
part i happen to like mental puzzles and
i tend to like taking an axe because i'm
a destructive
i'm a destructive person but at the same
time i happen to like the climbing of
the roots and so
i yes i've liked physics that's i've
liked physics as a kid i've liked math
as a kid and i'm attempting with the toe
podcast to to do both okay jp velek says
kurt if you could have the answer to one
question what would it be
jp i don't know that's again that's a
bit too much pressure just one question
i don't i don't know but there are some
there are questions that i think you
should think twice about if you truly
want the answer to
nicholas ramada says when is frank yang
so i mentioned again that i've
i've haven't been able to study for
frank king carl first in the ah lms
video you can are those videos which you
can look at to find more information
about this frank yang thank you so much
you sent me a long email
and and i appreciate it i haven't had a
chance to respond to frank i'm i
apologize i hope you know that i'm not
i'm not ignoring you i'm just extremely
terrified it would be one word to take a
look at it or not ready would be perhaps
a more copacetic word at some point i'll
i'll i'll speak to you
my my trepidation does seem to be
luckily
reducing with every passing week
by the
by the glory of the most high god and
and i'll this by the way a phrase from
bach
i'll be responding to you frank
shortly so perhaps in a month or two
months or three months okay so
frank and nicholas give me some more
time
i need
it ameliorates every week like i
mentioned just i need some more time
john john viz says when will he get
chris lange to speak with eric weinstein
if they're both interested then then yes
k
says
do you suffer from panic attacks
or anxiety related obstacles in your
life is socializing difficult
this diff going out in public places
difficult
sorry if it's too personal they said
no so luckily i don't
suffer from panic attacks and i don't
have agoraphobia i can go outside in
public
i
i
there's nothing wrong with me in that
respect
i
i have gone through a period somewhat
recently where almost every other
thought was an extremely fearful thought
i was about three months straight and i
had to carry beta blockers with me but
that's
well it's mollified now luckily
ink retreat studio says what happened to
part two of the sao pius interview i'm
going to do it in person with cell and
sal would like that as well we
communicate to each other over email
occasionally
and check in on one another the timing
right now is not right for either of us
chop citizen says
okay
many scientific philosophical
discoveries occurred from
a correct concise phrasing of the
question that contains the problem
and not from
initially conceptualizing the solution
that is to say do you believe that the
framing of the question is often the
most important step in the discovery of
the solution to that question i do think
that that's the case
many of the times often in mathematics
there's a phrase that says make your
definitions complex and your proofs
simple
which means
once you have the correct idea of what
you're
playing around with
then the proofs become trivial
and so certain questions like
well how was god there before anyone
else how does the causeless happen and
so on i don't know of how
the quote unquote how is the correct
frame
and to me it would be like saying what
time is the pen
or or how is the panoply
well what the heck does that mean it
perhaps it works at a syntactic level
but not as a semantic one like the
chomsky an idea of green colorless ideas
that sleep furiously i believe was it so
the mystic may say that one doesn't need
to do all of these verbal gymnastics
it's all a distraction and
rupert spiral might be on that they
feel like that because they're already
on a spiritual bend but there are large
swaths of the population the majority
perhaps not the minority but at least a
sizable portion 30 percent maybe greater
that aren't attracted to the eastern and
and mystical
method of knowing and that
one doesn't feel like the answer is i
just need to simply experience life and
meditate away into a blissful sea of
nothingness so
30 percent of the population may feel
like oh yes i do need to do that like i
can see that there's some truth to it
but they they don't do it they can't do
it they don't feel like that's
it doesn't jive with them and maybe they
don't know how to do i don't know how to
do that not all the time i've had
certain experiences like that so maybe
they don't have a reason
to do so enough to motivate them and to
find the how
the
toe podcast and the discord and the
community and so on is
somewhat helps with this or at least it
comes in and it's
the toe project or the toe channel is
like a process of explication of a of a
left a left brain investigation of a of
a right brain phenomenon it's not
because we disregard the the right brain
the experiential it's
it's it's because we see the importance
of it we just don't have a
uh
a ship to sail us from here to that
island to move us from our island to
another one the ships that work for
other people when people say hey all you
need to do is just meditate and just do
so and so they they don't work they
don't work for
for the logical analytical brain at
least not for many people like i said
perhaps thirty percent of people that's
in part what attracts that
thirty percent or i think a subset of
that thirty percent to the toe podcast
because
at least we're admitting that it just
doesn't jive with us
what i'm doing is trying to construct my
own boat and perhaps show by example how
others can construct their boat and they
can show me at least in the comment
section and on the discord and so on how
we can sail
to the promised land
by constructing a boat that is
is unexampled it's just for us it's
particular
and i see the utility in the
experiential approach i also see the
utility in the marriage between the
experiential and the analytical and so
many of those in the analytical will
disregard
the experiential so many in the
experiential will contem and disparage
the the analytical and say each one is
not needed only my approach well perhaps
perhaps so
or
what's more likely is perhaps that's
worked for you
and what what works for you doesn't
necessarily work for everyone else and
we all see this what
i think we're all well i think many of
us are
are tired of being told
that what one should do is
simply meditate in this manner and
simply realize quote unquote realize
quote unquote awaken awaken quote
unquote
loss of ego quote unquote loss of self
and many of these
misappropriated if i could use that word
misappropriated terms from the east
which actually are heavily laden in the
culture of the east and then they're
adopted in the west usually via some
psychedelic
insight
completely disentangled from the
communities of the east if you
told them your insights from
psychedelics they say oh my gosh you're
completely misguided that's not what we
meant at all you have misunderstood
you've taken a translation mistranslated
it mistranslated it and then adopted it
into english singularly when it should
have been
from the source from our
culture in our culture with multiple
people and it's not just an insight that
you get alone it's something you work
through with a
with a with a sangha is what diana
pasoka said with a community of people
so
perhaps there's something
amiss with the analytical approach
perhaps there's something amiss with the
experiential approach but perhaps
there's utility in both and perhaps
there's utility in the marriage between
them
slow says do you have a synthesis of the
top concepts and theories you've learned
from your guests it's all disconnected
currently i need i need to spend more
time integrating rather than
rather than learning and then going on
to the next one and then learning and
learning
logan says
what were you like in high school did
you have a hard time fitting in did you
win any awards did you know what you
wanted to do in life i i had no hard
time fitting in there was no
popular crowd unlike what you see in the
movies at least not in my high school
there were certainly unpopular crowds
but i wasn't in one of them
awards i think i won an award or two i i
don't recall my physics teacher was kind
to me and gave me great grades even
though i didn't do the assignments he
saw that
he he saw he said there was extreme
potential in me and i was just looking
i was
so lazy i wouldn't do the tests sorry i
would do extremely well on tests but i
would get zeros in the homework and i
didn't hand them in in fact i fought
with one of my math teachers
because he made me do matrix
multiplication for pages and pages and i
remember thinking
what's the point of this it's not even a
linear transformation you're just
getting me to multiply rows and columns
together so i had to go i went to the
school board and then the school board
sided with me
well
i don't know how i had the courage to to
do that as a high schooler to go up
against the teacher like that but i
guess my my
my unindustriousness got the better of
me
and
as far as what i wanted to do in life i
wanted to be a mathematician i believe
or a physicist i wanted in particular to
solve the riemann hypothesis
and come up with a toe with the theory
of everything so the signs of
of humoristic behavior were apparent at
an extremely early age
lar bowler said amazing kurt i really
hope this is a thing my number one
question would be how do you deal with
depression
i i
luckily i don't have depression i'm i'm
super lucky i don't have feelings of
sadness almost ever except well
they're short
lived and they're with respect to
watching a movie or a story or seeing
something on
seeing an image or or a video
and
it's not persistent it's more about
well i don't have persistent sadness at
all
where do you see yourself in one to five
to ten years
five years ten years who knows who knows
one year i have some plans i have
plenty of plans pale horse says what is
your mission in life
i
i
i don't i'm sorry pale horse i don't
know how to answer that i i haven't i
have an answer but it would take me far
too
long to dredge it up from the depths to
dredge it is that the correct word let
me see
yes that's correct so dredge up from the
depths antagonist says last question
antagonist number three how are you
right now i'm
exhausted i've been doing this for
almost 12 hours straight now because i
had some podcasts earlier today one with
gen zed another with greg henriques and
then prepping for this and then well i
don't need to go through what i was up
to and what i'm going to do after this
is 9 p.m i should have finished that i
was planning on finishing at 5 00 p.m or
so
5 p.m for the latest
and i have these lights here and these
are
what are called
sad lamps i believe seasonal affective
disorder not that i i have that luckily
i don't suffer from any such condition
but
it's it's just because they're
extremely lightweight lamps they mimic
the uv sorry they mimic the
the light of the sun for people who have
seasonal effective disorder i forgot
what they're called happy lamps
regardless the point is that this is
going to keep me up now because it's 9
p.m and i'm still looking at these
lights they should have shut off at 6 pm
so i'm feeling a bit flustered from that
i'm feeling extremely grateful that
people are interested in
in the theories of everything podcast
i'm wondering what the heck is my wife
doing she's probably urinated 10 times
over in that bedroom and just
shaking her fist wondering when the hell
am i gonna finish this and having her
ear against the door thinking is this
over this was supposed to be over two
hours ago what the heck is happening so
i'm gonna go check in on her if you're
wondering what i'm referring to this is
a reference to the fact that we have a
fairly tiny condo with only one washroom
which is directly behind me
during podcasts my poor wife has to wait
in the room with plastic cups to urinate
in
unfortunately until we can move out to
another place
i
i'm also thinking what else do i have to
do so
i
i'm hot
i
am happy hot as in temperature wise
because i haven't turned on the air
conditioning yet
i'm extremely happy about
about finishing this about
well
i'm
i'll just say i'm happy and i appreciate
the question
antagonist number three
thank you all for watching
again if you're interested in
supporting the theories of everything
podcast then do consider going to
patreon.com
there'll probably be another reference
of this toward the end there is it's a
standard audio that gets played
and
and i i just appreciate you
well i
160 000 subscribers holy moly that's
great i have many many plans for this
this is just the beginning i thought
that the tow podcast would end in three
years i remember thinking that and
saying that i think in the first ama
i now see it extending out to seven
years so seven years from this point so
maybe 2029 or 2028
and there are
there
well i'm just extremely excited to
show you what's coming up plenty is on
the horizon
thank you thank you all and have a great
night
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l
that is kurt jaimungle it's support from
the patrons and from the sponsors that
allow me to do this full-time every
dollar helps tremendously thank you
you